they say that in space no one can hear
you scream we'll see if that's still the
case when you're being attacked by
gruesome mutated humans in a prison on
the moon of Jupiter that's what will be
happening to you in the Callisto
protocol a game created by the Twisted
Minds behind Dead Space here's
everything to know about the Callisto
protocol
the Callisto protocol is a new original
survival horror game Set On You Guessed
It Callisto a moon of Jupiter more
specifically it's set in a prison called
Black Iron located on Callisto in 2320.
it's there that cargo pilot protagonist
Jacob Lee finds himself trapped as
mutating humans begin taking over and
murdering other inmates there are
mysteries on and in Callisto that Jacob
must uncover and as with all good
dystopian futuristic stories a mega
Corporation could be the problem it's
like someone's trying to cover up what's
happening here in this case United
Jupiter company Reigns Supreme and we're
willing to bet those inmates didn't just
start transforming into monsters for no
reason
foreign
like dead space before it's the Callisto
protocol is a third person survival
horror game with action elements there
will be a mix of up close melee combat
and ranged Weaponry letting you
improvise and decide what the best tool
in a specific situation is because of
the relatively limited ammunition just
like in most survival horror games you
won't be blasting away mindlessly while
trying to survive however powerful
weapons will still be able to destroy
limbs potentially slowing down enemies
as they approach just like dead spaces
Isaac Clarke Jacob Lee is just an
ordinary guy thrown into a terrifying
situation he doesn't have combat
training and the only weapons available
to him are what he can scrounge up from
around the prison
there will be several different enemy
types Jacob will go up against in the
Callisto protocol including robotic
prison guards as well as a variety of
mutated humans with direct confrontation
using weapons not always the best option
you may need to get creative so you
aren't overwhelmed or surrounded the
biophages look radically different from
standard humans and even with shotguns
melee weapons and the gravity-changing
grp device it won't be easy to defeat
them even a single enemy is a threat in
a lot of ways the biophages are very
similar to dead space's Necromorphs both
enemies are heavily mutated creatures
that stretch and contort the human form
into something while monstrous manages
to still be terrifyingly recognizable
Jacob will meet some human characters
around the prison who haven't turned
into terrifying monsters including
members of a resistance group who are
determined to get to the bottom of the
Shady dealings of the United Jupiter
company but in in an attempt to not cut
through the tension too frequently the
Callisto protocol tells a lot of its law
and additional Side Stories through
audio logs so the developer recommends
you check them out the game will utilize
current gen Hardware in interesting ways
not only will there be a 60 frames per
second performance mode when the game
launches but haptic feedback on
PlayStation 5 controllers will be used
to amplify the feeling of enemy bones
shattering when you land a powerful blow
to keep tension at an all-time high the
game won't feature a map so you can't
even get a reprieve by opening it when
planning the game scares the team
operated on the ethos that there are no
rules each scare was crafted
specifically to land with the team
balancing timing and tension to scare
the crap out of players
if you're interested in learning about
why horror is so impactful why don't you
take a look at one of these two features
we have up on the channel right now a
link in below the game's director Glenn
Schofield revealed sometimes we make
players wait 10 or 15 minutes for a big
scare sometimes we hit them with two or
three in a row sometimes we build up a
ton of tension and get players ready for
a jump scare then don't deliver it it's
kind of like a game of cat and mouse as
soon as you become predictable it's over
the Callisto protocol won't have
multiplayer but there will be a season
pass for future DLC the season pass
includes a number of new Cosmetics
including the outer way Watchtower and
engineer skin collections it also
includes a new Mode called contagion
where you'll get fewer Health drops and
reduced ammo there's also a wave-based
Mode called Riot where you can use
credits to upgrade your weapons and just
try to survive as long as you can
there'll also be future story DLC both
Riot and contagion include new death
animations for Jacob which was met with
some skepticism when announced with some
fans believing Striking Distance had
paywall features from the main game to
clear things up game director Glenn
Schofield tweeted to be clear we're not
holding anything back from the main game
for the season pass we haven't even
started work on this content yet it's
all new stuff that we'll be working on
in the New Year fans have asked for even
more deaths so we're making it a
priority next year
after Dead Space 3 was released and its
developer visceral games eventually
shattered it appeared the age of AAA
science fiction survival horror games
was coming to an end but that wasn't the
case Glenn Schofield who co-created the
original dead space before founding Call
of Duty Studio Sledgehammer Games
returned to survival horror with the
Callisto protocol developed at his new
company Striking Distance Studios the
Callisto protocol wears its dead space
influence proudly with Schofield even
saying I'm not going to shy away from a
good idea because it was in one of my
games all game makers look at ideas from
other games Picasso said good artists
borrow great artists steal well why not
steal from myself but the cluster
protocol is aiming for a scarier and
more atmospheric take on the genre than
what Dead Space eventually became by its
third installment
foreign
Schofield isn't the only big name
attached to the Callisto protocol Jacob
Lee is played by actor Josh Duhamel best
known for the Transformers movies and
Call of Duty World War II Karen fukahara
from the boys and Suicide Squad also has
a starring role as Danny Nakamura leader
of the outer way a resistance group who
are trying to square up against the
United Jupiter company at one point in
development the Callisto protocol was
planned to exist within the pubg
universe as the game is published by
krafton however this is no longer the
case with any connection being limited
to some Easter eggs scattered throughout
the game pubg is at least from the
weaponry and setting set close to the
modern era while the Callisto protocol
takes place hundreds of years in the
future and far away from Earth
foreign
[Applause]
School releases on December 2nd 2022 and
will be available for PC PS4 PS5 Xbox
One and Xbox series X and S there are
three different editions the day one
edition digital deluxe edition and the
collectors edition the day one edition
includes the base game a retro prisoner
character skin and two retro prisoner
weapon skins if you buy any edition on
PlayStation you get a couple of other
benefits such as 48-hour Early Access
for upcoming DLC and a Contraband pack
filled with items that will help you out
during the game it retails for 59.99 on
PC and last gen and 69.99 on current gen
the digital deluxe edition features all
of the previously mentioned items as
well as the game season pass it's 79.99
on last gen and PC and 89.99 on current
gen the Callisto protocols collectors
edition features everything previously
mentioned but also comes with a fancy
steelbook case a comic two collectible
pins and a statue of Jacob it's
249.99 for current gen and 239.99 for
the previous if you're in Japan and
looking to play You're unfortunately out
of luck as the game will not be released
in the country Striking Distance Studios
said via its Japanese Twitter account
that the localized version for Japan
will be discontinued and that anyone who
pre-ordered will get a refund in a tweet
translated by VGC the studio said we
have determined that the game cannot
pass the zero rating in its current
state and that changing the content will
not provide the experience that players
expect we would appreciate your
understanding in Japan there's not long
to wait until the Callisto protocol
launches and if you want to check out
some more gameplay as well as Hands-On
Impressions make sure to subscribe to
Gamespot on YouTube and check out
gamespot.com you can find me on Twitter
at Lucy James games and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]